é essa força da década de 30
ali sentado está meu avô com o time de
trabalho dele eu nasci há algumas
décadas depois e quando eu nasci o meu
vôo já era um homem muito bem sucedido
a minha família a família de gente muito
trabalhadora e eu passava as férias na
casa do meu avô tinha muito orgulho que
ele era um homem importante na cidade e
o meu avô tinha mania de fazer uma
brincadeira comigo era a primeira a
primeira neta a única neta
durante muitos anos e ele fazia uma
brincadeira comigo que ele não sabia do
impacto que tinha
cadê o botão o não tá aí tinha isso
ele perguntava pra mim eu acordava para
tomar café da manhã e ele perguntava pra
mim porque você acorda cedo para ficar
mais tempo sem fazer nada e aquilo ia
assim às vezes sente um pouco de
vergonha ele fala por brincadeira e às
vezes aquilo me incomodava às vezes eu
não dava muita bola e essa pergunta foi
levando os pensamentos que eu deveria
ter para o resto da minha vida assim
porque é que eu estou acordando cedo e
eu tinha uma uma aflição que era eu
queria fazer alguma coisa de relevante
eu não sabia o quê
mas eu queria acordar cedo e fazer
alguma coisa que vale muito a pena
eu estava na primeira é a primeira
faculdade eu tinha 40 anos já quando eu
fiz a primeira faculdade e eu fui com o
grupo de de alunos visitar esse museu e
quando ele estava em construção o museu
oscar niemayer lá em casa e lá em
curitiba a gente visitando aquele museu
enorme gigante ele é um ele é muito
poderoso e em construção ele era maior
ainda e olhando aquele museu e venda
grandiosidade
e pensando nos artistas que um dia vamos
colocar seus quadros na parede e eu
pensei meu deus eu realmente eu não vou
conseguir fazer nada de relevante na
vida já tenho 40 anos não vai mais dar
tempo
aí há o pessoal que estava nos
ciceroneando no museu falou se olha
agora a gente vai pra uma sala que vocês
vão ter uma surpresa
aí entramos nessa sala sentamos lá de
repente baixo um telão isso era ano 2000
por aí era muito difícil ver uma vídeo
conferência e eu falei nossa uma
videoconferência uma coisa super legal
né
e quem aparece na videoconferência o
oscar niemayer
com quase 90 anos falando de toda a
expectativa que ele estava da
inauguração do museu o quanto era
importante e que ele não estava lá
porque ele tinha aula de filosofia no
outro dia de manhã e ele não perdia há
áudio filosofia por nada desse mundo
eu falei nossa eu tenho 50 anos para
chegar lá
então ainda dá tempo foi esse dia que eu
pensei nossa 40 anos ainda vai dar pra
fazer alguma coisa é esse o seu animal
está trabalhando até os 90 e ainda tem o
tempo
enfim eu vou contar um pouco da minha
história pra vocês eu com 36 anos
comecei a fazer minha primeira faculdade
eu era dona de casa já 18 anos estava
longe da escola
tive algumas dificuldades pra poder
chegar a fazer o primeiro vestibular
tive que me separar tive que ficar bem
pobre
tive que me separar os meus filhos e aí
com todas essas dificuldades eu tinha
uma mais que eu não sabia que era uma
dificuldade mas alguma coisa que me
atrapalhava eu tenho défice de atenção e
é um défice de atenção num nível
bastante alto para conseguir fazer esse
meu primeiro vestibular e era tão
importante passar porque afinal já tinha
36 anos e ainda não tinha nenhuma
faculdade queria fazer alguma coisa da
vida estava me separando estava sem
dinheiro e eu tinha que realizar alguma
coisa eu criei um método para estudar
eu não sabia porque eu não consegui
estudar
eu sabia que tendo algumas técnicas
recordando os papéis vinhos colorindo me
esforçando eu ia conseguir chegar a
algum lugar
no começo antes de desenvolver essa
técnica e eu estudava tudo em uma semana
na outra semana tinha esquecido
absolutamente tudo
aí eu comecei a fazer um teste mas o que
estudava dois dias antes dois dias
depois também especial tudo eu não sabia
né que é o défice de atenção que assim
as pessoas acham que deve ter atenção é
uma coisa que atrapalha só gente mas
atrapalha todo mundo que está em volta
da gente porque acaba espirrando né eu
sou uma pessoa extremamente atrapalhada
pra vir pra cá eu marquei a os assentos
do avião tudo trocado eu marquei 18 para
mim o 18 o meu marido e daí assim eu
nunca sei a hora que eu vou pegar semana
passada tinha uma reunião super
importante em são paulo eu cheguei três
minutos atrasado porque confunde o
horário é sempre assim a minha vida né e
não é uma coisa legal até engraçado
assim quando a gente conta
mas da hora que acontece tenho muita
raiva sáb
e aí fui criança e sua metodologia que
eu não sabia que era uma metodologia era
um jeito de eu sobreviver
naquela situação onde eu precisava
estudar e eu não lembrava do que tinha
estudado e aí essa metodologia me ajudou
a passar na primeira faculdade eu na
segunda faculdade aí eu vi que ainda era
pouco e comecei com 40 anos eu fui fazer
o meu segundo vestibular
aí eu tive que correr que foi logo
depois do oscar niemayer né então eu
fazia faculdade de filosofia de manhã à
tarde a estudar o mestrado e à noite
fazia pós graduação e finais de semana
trabalhava porque estava numa situação
financeira um pouco complicado um pouco
bastante complicada quando tudo estava
acontecendo e eu estava achando que
estava fazendo uma coisa relevante na
minha vida estudando fazendo coisa
trabalhando meus quadros da um sucesso
papá o meu filho de oito anos tem um avc
e aí eu falei agora não vou conseguir
mesmo né três faculdades um filho com
avc tendo que trabalhar e sem dinheiro
realmente não vai rolar
aí eu dei um jeito e voltei a resgatar
aquela metodologia que me ajudou a
passar no primeiro vestibular que tenha
então estava parado né
e comecei a estudar de novo sozinha
falei com os professores e eu aparecia
na aula quando dava e coisas não davam
estava na fisioterapia do com o meu
filho enquanto ele está fazendo
fisioterapia ficava no carro estudando e
eu fui potencializando esse modo de
estudar
aí eu tive que potencializar muito
porque no lugar de lembrar para um
vestibular eu tinha que lembrar que o
mestrado pra pós-graduação e pra
faculdade de filosofia e esse método
acabou se tornando a minha profissão
comecei a escrever livros didáticos e o
que meus livros didáticos sempre tinham
de retorno de quem de quem via era nossa
consegui entender tudo nossa tá fácil de
entender nossa como você fala fácil como
é rápido e entender o que você fala
e aí até que em 2010
um desses livros didáticos vocês terem
noção da complexidade esse livro tinha
um filme que era pra ensinar filosofia
admite nas escolas públicas de curitiba
para crianças né então fazer crianças e
é aprender sobre nite e ainda que eles
prestassem atenção foi um desafio é esse
filme foi para 30 países e foi escrito
em conjunto com uma amiga minha ele foi
para 30 países ele recebeu muitos
prêmios e um deles foi selecionado por
japan prize é o maior evento de midia
educativa do mundo chegando no japão
traz eles fizeram uma uma entrevista
comigo fizeram um documentário sobre
esse jeito de ensinar e como é que eu
conseguia traduzir uma coisa tão
complicada para uma criança
logo depois a unicef e me chamou para ir
a cuba para falar sobre essa metodologia
nas escolas cubana e me tomaram como
exemplo de educação na américa latina e
as coisas estavam indo muito bem quando
2010 e falei nossa eu já tenho uma
poupança tinha eu já estou com a vida
mais ou menos estabilizada
está na hora de eu me arriscar né eu
resolvi montar uma startup de educação e
pensar empreendedorismo de impacto
social e não sabe exatamente o que quer
o impacto social na época
mas eu sabia mais ou menos o que é o
empreendedorismo que é aquele bichinho
que faz a gente ficar muito ansioso
quando está tudo acomodado né que a
gente acha que pode fazer uma coisa mais
com aquilo que está acontecendo na vida
da gente e aí a gente descobriu a base
da pirâmide né a base da pirâmide
basicamente são aquelas pessoas que têm
uma baixa escolaridade que tem um
universo um pouco diferente da classe a
e b que faz toda a metodologia para elas
e a gente começou a estudar como é que
essas pessoas que excepciona não há a
aprendizagem como é que essas pessoas
vivem e sentir muita empatia por quem
tem dificuldade de aprendizagem e não é
porque a pessoa tem menos inteligência
ou mais inteligência é porque elas têm
um outro contexto elas aprenderam é é
diferente é passar o ensinamento de uma
pessoa que deu 40 livros do que uma
pessoa que nunca leu um livro é aquela
pessoa vai ter um outro tipo de
atividade de dificuldade nessa lida e aí
a gente focou a metodologia do já
entende que é para a capacitação
profissional para pessoas com baixa
escolaridade então a gente havia uma é
uma pesquisa que eu fiz da áfrica eu fui
fazer um documentário em são tomé e
príncipe e perco ver um pouco com essas
crianças como é que era aquele universo
como é que elas reagiam às imagens aos
ensinamentos de ali embaixo a gente
capacitou os pedreiros da vila olímpica
e lá tem uma coisa muito legal os
pedreiros eles foram super ficaram muito
felizes a gente está mostrando o
trabalho deles e ensinando para os
outros que eles tinham uma certa
dificuldade de passar para o companheiro
do lado como é que ia ser feita a tal da
parede e aí quando a gente terminou tudo
nós filmamos tudo e aí eu perguntei pra
ele se escuta eu sei que por um
apresentador normalmente por um
apresentador para essas aulas e o que
vocês pensam e apresentador um homem
assim assado não a gente tem uma mulher
apresentando é legal
e essa mulher como é que ela vai ser né
ela sequer uma morena loira uma ruiva
uma negra o que quer dizer eu quero uma
negra mas não me apareça uma negrinha
magrela igual vocês são eu quero uma
negrona reforçada e foi muito legal
porque neles caron e aí a gente foi
entendendo que a pesquisar muito grupo
social o qual a gente está tentando
ensinar alguma coisa é muito importante
porque são eles que me dizem o que que é
aquela empatia não é não sou eu não é o
diretor de uma empresa que vai me dizer
como é que eu vou ensinar aquelas
pessoas que ele tem mau contato né
mas seja a semana passada naquela
reunião que eu perdi eu quase perdi eu
acabei pegando outro vôo
eu fui falar com o vice presidente de
uma das maiores empresas do brasil eu
estava falando com duas diretoras antes
dele né e aí ela escutando pode usar os
problemas que eu tinha que resolver papá
e daí uma hora elas pararam a se falar
assim nossa mas o vice-presidente falou
pra gente parar de contar as coisas pra
você porque a gente não quer influenciar
a gente quer que você ensina do jeito
que você quiser
e do jeito que eles querem ser ensinados
isso foi um grande prêmio para mim
porque eles chegaram porque muitas
empresas chegam à gente e tentam fazer
mais do mesmo eles querem que a gente
vai lá trazer uma coisa inovadora fazer
uma coisa diferente mas aí me dizem as
regras que eu tenho que seguir estão me
pagando pra fazer do meu jeito que além
das regras deles né e hoje a gente já
consegue se impor e falar olha a gente
vai falar com eles os trabalhadores vão
passar pra gente como é que eles querem
que a gente enfim ea metodologia vai ser
nossa mas o jeito vai ser o jeito deles
aí a gente foi sendo reconhecido em
vários momentos ali eu ganhei o prêmio
am
a história de sucesso do estadão ali
negócio cria método disse que acelera o
aprendizado
a gente foi vendo aos poucos que esse
método realmente comprovadamente acelera
aprendizagem para a base da pirâmide
ali a gente ganhou o prêmio startup do
ano passado do pequeno segredo empresa
grandes negócios e imagens que
transformam então a gente em si através
de imagens a gente consegue passar
ensinamento para a base da pirâmide e
aqui eu fui convidada para escrever um
livro que está sendo fazendo um super
sucesso que é como aprender mais e
melhor estudando sozinho então ajudando
as pessoas que estudam sozinhos como
potencializar aquilo com regras fáceis
não tem nada demais é uma coisa muito
simples
e aí o resultado de tudo isso são 33
prêmios através do mundo 38 livros
escritos 31 filmes e uma imensa
satisfação e poder
o meu vou não tá vivo hoje mas eu posso
dizer pra ele que eu a gente acorda cedo
eu e meu time na verdade eu só tenho a
idéia é o meu time e executa é pra
mostrar que a gente consegue melhorar um
pouco o mundo a gente acorda cedo em
curitiba é uma cidade muito fria e com
muita satisfação pra tentar melhorar um
pouco o mundo por meio da educação e
fazer com que a educação chegue a essas
pessoas não da forma com que a uma
platéia seleta julga que seja importante
eles aprenderem mais da forma que eles
acham que eles devem aprender a gente
faz essa adaptação e tem sido muito
legal eu retorno deles e é por isso que
estou aqui
e na verdade é por causa desse time
também que me ajuda a executar tudo isso
porque ninguém faz nada sozinho e no
caso já entendi é a mesma coisa
muito obrigada